thank you for your time mr corbin and
condolences as well i'm sure you could
hear what natasha and i were discussing
there she was raising the point that in
some ways maybe colin powell was almost
set up and became a fall guy the public
fall guy for the invasion of iraq
well
vice president cheney said you're the
only one who has the credibility to make
the case given you know some of the
other statements that the uh and
backgrounds of the other people in the
administration
and i spoke to him after he did it
when i was not no longer in government
nor was he and he said it was a big
mistake but what he was really trying to
do was be a good soldier you know if
you're a soldier
and you get an order as long as it's not
illegal
and you don't agree with it you still
have to carry it out and i think what he
was trying to do he knew they were going
to go
he knew
that you couldn't make a definitive case
but there was a reasonable chance that
some of this intelligence might be right
and don't forget
the statement that they wanted him to
give he didn't give i mean he cut it
down he and his uh colleague rich
armitage who i also work with basically
you know took out a lot of the the stuff
that was in there originally so i think
he was trying to compromise and do the
best he could and unfortunately it has
permanently tarnished his reputation as
a statesman but not as a soldier